bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette édition
de fin de semaine de votre journal
préparé par la rédaction de tv fils
aujourd'hui 1er juillet vendredi 1er
juillet nous reviendrons sur la sortie
du royaume-uni de l'europe depuis une
semaine les réunions se multiplient les
élus tentent de rassurer
invité pour commenter cette actualité
pierre lequiller député des yvelines
conseiller régional d'île de france
président en ile-de-france europe à
versailles l'osmothèque fête ses 25 ans
le conservatoire international du parfum
se visite avec l'odorat il veille sur
plus de 3000 fragrance de tout temps
dont 400 disparus du marché et puis que
retenir de l'actualité de cette semaine
rendez vous en deuxième partie de ce
journal pour le zapping de l'information
locale entre hausse du passe navigo les
innovations du site brigue challenger à
saint quentin en yvelines qui
impressionne le gouvernement et puis le
premier budget commun aux yvelines et au
département des hauts-de-seine
on commence pour l'instant avec l'open
de golf qui s'est ouvert hier jeudi la
compétition bat son plein le public est
une nouvelle fois présent à rappelons
qu'il s'agit de la 100e édition et que
nous sommes maintenant à seulement deux
ans du grand tournoi de la ryder cup
michael almy dans l'open de france le
plus gros rendez-vous golfique de
l'hexagone a débuté ce jeudi à saint
quentin en yvelines pour cette 100e
édition les organisateurs s'attendent à
accueillir plus de 60000 spectateurs sur
les quatre jours de compétition
les supporters ont déjà pris place à
côté des greens si un tournoi qui attire
beaucoup de monde donc un passionnant
avec des grands joueurs donc c'est
passionnant d'être ici je pense que ça
un tournoi qui monte en puissance
surtout avec le la ryder cup dans deux
ans je crois que
on aura de plus en plus de grands
joueurs sur l'open de france
la vingtaine de loges de l'open de
france est également garni comme tous
les ans d'une capacité de 50 à 250
personnes les espaces équipés de balcons
accueil des professionnels et des
célébrités
ici on a la chance d'aller voir arriver
on a la chance de stresser avec eux
parce qu'il ya quand même pas mal de dos
il ya du vent et quelques gouttes de
pluie mais ça va pas durer
moment en fait on est content de se
retrouver ici
sur le plan sportif le public peut voir
en action huit vainqueurs de majeurs 87
vainqueur sur le tour et 18 jours de
ryder cup
la super star de cette édition 2016 et
le nord irlandais rory mcilroy numéro 3
mondial au niveau de vente de
billetterie
c'est important c'est énorme jusqu'à
remboursant com com et la moyenne et on
le ressent complètement et on le sent
aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya énormément de
monde on n'a jamais vu autant de monde
un jeudi le premier jour à 8 heures ce
matin ces foules
le golf national fort à ses comptes ce
dimanche 3 juillet au soir la coupe sera
remise aux alentours de 17h30 au
vainqueur
le royaume uni a donc décidé de quitter
l'europe près de 52% des électeurs
britanniques se sont prononcés en faveur
de ce départ nous allons y revenir à
présent tout juste une semaine après ce
coup de tonnerre dans un instant ce sera
avec pierre lequiller député blinois
conseiller régional il a également a
travaillé sur l'élaboration du traité de
lisbonne mais pour l'instant écouter cet
universitaire spécialiste des questions
européennes c'est au micro de nicolas
landry d'un côté françois hollande
demande à ce qu'on aille vite et que
l'on aille vers plus d'intégration de
l'autre côté en gris merkel disait il
faut laisser le temps au temps et +
intégration ça ne va pas forcément de
soi
qu'est-ce qu'on a eue après la rencontre
de lundi matin entre françois hollande
angela merkel et matteo renzi une
déclaration commune des trois qui disait
d'une part il faut aller vite
donc là c'est la vision françois
hollande qui l'emportent et notre part
il ne faut pas tout de suite proposé un
nouveau traité un gala merkel a
d'ailleurs dit qu'il n'y aurait pas tout
cas que négocier un nouveau traité ou
modifiée de ce thé lisbonne n'était pas
la priorité donc là c'est plutôt la
vision merkel qui l'emportent finalement
ce que ces partis d'extrême droite ou
populistes appellent de leurs voeux
retour en europe pourrait se révéler une
sorte de moule de boomerang en fait
qu'il revient en pleine face si jamais
c'est ça se passe mal pour le
royaume-uni économiquement politiquement
socialement je pense qu'il faut éviter
qu'on organise en europe des référendums
pour ans contre l'europe parce que la
véritable question ce n'est pas ça c'est
plutôt calé l'europe que l'on veut et
comment le royaume uni va tu maintenant
concrètement sortir de l'union
européenne sur le plan juridique et
goûté une fois de plus la réponse de cet
universitaire c'est un article qui quand
on regarde et on le lit véritablement
nous permet de comprendre pourquoi est
ce que david cameron à temps pour
déclencher un article 50 parce qu'une
fois qu'on a déclenché cet article là il
n'y a plus de possibilité de revenir en
arrière la procédure est irréversible et
ensuite l'union européenne et le royaume
uni ont un délai de deux ans pour
négocier la sortie et l'article 5 ans
dit bien que si au bout les deux ans
aucun accord n'a été trouvé entre
l'union européenne et le royaume uni le
royaume-uni sort dé facto de l'union
européenne et tous le droit nyons arrêt
de sa part et de s'appliquer à lui on
estime aujourd'hui qu'il est à peu près
quinze mille normes européennes qui ont
été transposées ou qui s'applique
directement royaume-uni donc toutes ces
nobles
il va bien falloir les faire
réapparaître au royaume uni
donc ça va prendre beaucoup de temps et
qu'il y avait d'intéressant surtout avec
la présence britannique au sein de
l'union c'était que ont apporté dans
l'union et à la cour de justice de
l'union européenne
des cultures juridiques différentes et
notamment une culture britannique
juridique qui est une culture de common
law qu'on ne connaît absolument pas ou
quasiment pas sur le continent je ne
reçois donc à présent pierre lequiller
bonsoir c'est député conseiller régional
vous êtes aussi le monsieur europe de
l'île de france puisque vous êtes le
président de l'association ile de france
europe la semaine dernière le royaume
uni a donc décidé de sortir de l'europe
c'est le verdict d'un référendum tout le
monde joue un petit peu à se faire peur
et finalement aujourd'hui c'est officiel
on vient d'entendre juste avant un
spécialiste universitaire sur cette
question européenne
est-ce que vous aussi vous vous partager
son sentiment l'europe va perdre
beaucoup
avec le départ de l'angleterre s'est
très
difficile de répondre aujourd'hui c'est
très difficile de répondre aujourd'hui
je pense pour dire la vérité que
l'angleterre va plus perdre que que
l'europe
d'ailleurs on le voit dans les réactions
de la classe politique britannique quand
on voit que le meneur de jeu qui voulait
prendre la place de cameron
improvisation se défend de jeter le gant
et lierse et on al'impression de de la
pièce de shakespeare match de hobart de
nothing c'est à dire beaucoup de bruit
pour rien quoi et beaucoup de bruit pour
rien mais mais mais saad est
effectivement très important pour
l'instant ce qui se passe c'est la
panique
en grande bretagne le fait que sur le
plan politique d'abord les deux parties
explose 1 et le parti conservateur comme
le parti travailliste puisque monsieur
courbit n'a été le leader qui n'a pas
fait suffisamment campagne paul holman a
été condamnée par 176 de ses députés
dont 80% de ses députés pratiquement le
parti conservateur n'en parlons pas que
l'ecosse a fait une demande officielle
en ce sens dans la première mini s'est
rendu à bruxelles pour demander à ce que
les causes restent dans l'union
européenne et l'irlande ça pose aussi
énormément de problème donc pour
l'instant il ya une véritable panique de
l'autre côté
et visiblement il n'y avait pas de plan
b
mais justement vous pensez que même
malgré ce référendum le royaume uni pour
revenir sur sa décision de quitter et
finalement ne jamais enclenché ce fameux
article 50 qui permet de lancer la
procédure de sortie
je ne pense pas je pense qu'un
référendum même s'il est consultatif ou
en bretagne
et que le parlement on peut décider le
contraire je pense que la force du
scrutin fait qu' il ne ne pourront pas
revenir sur leur décision
mais il reste que le parlement lui même
et à très forte majorité pour rester
dans l'union européenne
il était très forte majorité pour rester
dans l'union européenne et que on le
voit très probablement c'est une
partisane du remain c'est à dire de
rester d'un an qui va être élu premier
ministre est elle qui est favorite
theresa may donc on est on est avec un
point d'interrogation connaissant les
britanniques pour cause je suis à moitié
britannique ma mère était anglaise je
suis né à l'ombre ils vont essayer de
négocier
il était un pied dedans un pied dehors
ils vont essayer d'être un pied dehors
un pied dedans donc ils vont essayer de
négocier mais en position d'infériorité
parce que ce qui est très grave pour la
grande bretagne c'est l'incertitude
sur le plan économique c'est dramatique
il ya plein d'entreprises qui sont déjà
en train d'envisager de déménager à
paris ou à francfort notamment dans le
domaine financier
il ya déjà des dispositions qui sont
prises parce que désordre dès lors
qu'ils ont pas ce qu'on appelle le
passeport européen ils peuvent plus agir
dans tout temps à partir de londres
et ça sera à partir de francfort ou de
paris ou d'une autre ville européenne et
donc il ya de leur part et aussi de
notre part parce que nous aussi on a
besoin que les entreprises le monde
économique soit face à une situation
stable clair on a besoin que les choses
aillent très vite et ils ont besoin que
les choses aillent très vite c'est
l'espoir qu'on a que ça ne dure pas trop
longtemps
khalid paris justement parler tout de
même deux des enjeux ne serait ce que
pour paris de peut être devenir aussi
confirmé une place-forte susurre sur la
scène européenne madame est justement
valérie pécresse voilà vous êtes
conseiller régional valérie pécresse qui
a plaidé pour notamment une révision du
régime des impatriés qui permet aux
salariés venus de l'étranger de
bénéficier des réductions fiscales
voilà on voit déjà les aussi qu' il y a
une carte à jouer
voilà à tout à fait mais un pécresse a
même fait une déclaration disant que les
entreprises britanniques ou les
entreprises étrangères installées en
grande bretagne sont invités à venir
dans la
dans la région ile de france c'est un
très beau pied de nez parce que je me
souviens que quand monsieur johnson qui
était maire de londres avait reçu
monsieur du pays lui avait dit en
rigolant parce que c'est son style vous
êtes dans la cinquième ville française
dans ce cas londres il ya cinq cent
mille français qui sont installés là-bas
ba aujourd'hui les rôles sont inversés
je trouve très bien que la présidente du
conseil régional face à un appel et
fasse en sorte que les entreprises
soient bien accueillis les entreprises
qui le voudront soient bien accueillis
dans la région parisienne on parle des
conséquences pour le royaume uni on
parle économie aussi et des enjeux et du
rôle à jouer ne serait-ce que pour la
région ile-de-france pour attirer malgré
tout être un petit peu profit de cette
situation très délicate
néanmoins il va falloir reconstruire
aussi l'europe et réconcilier l'europe
avec les peuples et ça c'est aussi un
enjeu qui concerne tous les politiques
alors je vais quand même aussi redonner
quelques éléments de biographie vous
concernant pour montrer que vous
maîtrisez quand même bien cette question
puisque vous avez été membre de la
convention sur l'avenir de l'europe
chargé d'établir un projet de
constitution européenne vous étiez aussi
pour l'ump chargé des affaires
européennes vice président du parti
populaire européen vice président du
mouvement européen pour la france
président de la commission des affaires
européennes à l'assemblée nationale est
aujourd'hui l'europe va mal
est ce que vous le vivez aussi que comme
un échec de la classe politique je le
vis comme
comme un
oui comme il secoue ces normes comme il
ce que ces normes
comme je le disais aussi bien pour la
grande bretagne que pour que pour
l'union européenne c'est une secousse
énorme mais il faut pas tout négative
est d'abord le scrutin a été quand même
entâché de
de beaucoup de mensonges d'une violence
extrême d'une xénophobie qu'on n'avait
jamais vu en grande bretagne alors qu'en
fait ils ont pas de problème d'immigrés
et ils ont un problème de deux migrants
européens est principalement polonais
ils ont trois cent cinquante mille
polonais en grande bretagne enfin regard
grande bretagne et donc le le contexte
de la migration chez nous à jouer chez
eux
deuxièmement ils ont une particularité
c'est évidemment leur passé prestigieux
un des slogans c'était great gatsby
weight game c'est à dire rendez la
grande brune labre le royaume uni grand
à nouveau et c'est une référence en 1940
monsieur boris johnson avait écrit un
livre sur thur chine il ya quelques mois
donc ce n'était pas par hasard
en l'occurrence crois que tu rates il
serait absolument pas comporté comme il
l'a fait et puis il ya eu des mensonges
éhontés qu'ils ont effacé sur leur bus
c'est à dire qu'il donnait 350 millions
par semaine à l'union européenne et
qu'ils allaient affecter un
au système d'assurance est donc d'abord
il ya eu tromperie et monsieur fade qui
est proche de madame le pen a avoué que
ses 350 millions il ne pourrait pas les
donner à la sécurité sociale vont chaque
mois donc le jour même du résultat
donc on voit là le deuxième le deuxième
aspect qu'il faut bien voir je lui ai
dit c'est décosse et l'irlande et le
troisième espèce et un vote où 75% des
jeunes ont voté pour rester autrement
dit ça a été un vote de deux générations
là il y avait les nostalgiques à partir
de 55 ans les nostalgiques de la 2942 la
grande bretagne qui effectivement s'est
dressé contre hitler et qui a été a été
extraordinaire et puis c'est aspect
insulaire bon mais c'est une nostalgie
et le problème c'est qu'ils vont avoir
besoin de l'union européenne nos
économies sont inter connectés nous
exportons hauteur nous les français 12
milliards d'euros vers la grande
bretagne pour revenir sur les peuples il
ya même s'il n'y a pas d'euro phobie on
le voit avec les sondages lorsque se
pose la question ou non d'organiser un
même un référendum en france par exemple
les gens préfèrent ne pas organiser ce
référendum même s'il n'y a pas d'euro
phobie ya quand même un euroscepticisme
réel les ya une vraie défiance vis-à-vis
de l'europe on a l'impression que plus
de contraintes pour les peuples car
aucun atout vous avez tout à fait raison
on a échoué
globalement je ne cherche pas les
responsabilités mais sur le problème des
migrations qui ça a joué un rôle
important dans bref un dingue comme je
vous le disais tout à l'heure
et donc je crois que comme nous le
proposons nous les républicains nicolas
sarkozy il faut refaire schengen avec
une direction politique de schengen
deuxième chose il faut absolument en
faire une opportunité puisque la grande
bretagne s'en va eh bien faisons de la
zone euro une zone beaucoup plus forte
beaucoup plus audacieuse sur les thèmes
qui intéressent les citoyens c'est à
dire la croissance et l'emploi
alors on a fait le plan hincker c'est
bien mais il faudrait qu'on ait une
politique commune de l'industrie une
politique commune de l'énergie une
politique commune de la recherche et
donc il faut qu'on mette à la tête de la
zone euro un président stable qui soit
qui soit responsable de la gouvernance
économique aussi et puis la troisième
chose c'est qu'il faut parfois exagérée
à une critique parfois exagéré mais que
l'europe se détourne des problèmes de
détails
des normes
excessive et ça c'est facile à faire
il ya des systèmes qui sont mis en place
la comitologie fjep intrus dont les
détails qui font que des décisions peu
démocratiques sont prises sur des points
finalement tout à fait secondaires comme
la taille des des paniers de pêche ou et
c'est ça il faut laisser tomber
complètement ça pour bien montrer on
s'occupe des problèmes réels des
européens et ça il y à une impulsion à
donner nous avons présenté au nicolas
sarkozy a présenté au bureau politique
deux des républicains
une motion qui comprend ces différents
points et qui a été adopté à l'unanimité
y compris bien sûr sur le nom
élargissement de l'europe surtout non
ferme à l'entrée de la turquie comme on
l'a toujours dit et je regrette que le
président hollande s'embarque en ce
moment sur la négociation d'un chapitre
tout à fait capital pour la turquie
pour conclure en deux mots l'avenir sera
radieux pour l'europe vous êtes confiant
non ils soient pas radieux il faut être
optimiste
il faut qu'on travaille il faut compter
100 live du travail à faire il ya du
travail pour la rendre véritablement
efficace et dès lors pour faire entendre
aux citoyens qui comme vous le dit très
justement sont attachés à l'europe les
citoyens français on doit y avoir un
gros soupir allemand mais ils sont
attachés à l'europe mais il envoie les
défauts et il faut que nous partis
politiques et ça va devenir
inévitablement le sujet principal de la
collection présidentielle des élections
législatives et même des sénatoriales de
l'année prochaine
je suis content que l'ordre
un sujet capital de ces élections
majeures merci pierre lequiller députés
les conseils régional et je le rappelle
président de l'association europe ile de
france merci à vous nous poursuivrons ce
journal avec un tout autre sujet les 25
ans de l'osmothèque de versailles un
musée qui préserve de nombreux parfums
dont certains sont aujourd'hui très rare
et justement jeudi soir une conférence
sur le thème de la postérité était
organisée c'est un lieu unique au monde
près de quatre mille parfums sont
conservés ici un trésor inestimable
précieusement gardés dans la cave de
l'osmothèque depuis 25 ans des créations
vulnérables mais véritable joyau de
l'histoire je dirais jusqu'aux années
1950 à peu près la parfumerie était
essentiellement françaises d'être un
vrai patrimoine et donc ont dominé le
monde qui on peut lire entre paris et
los et voilà maintenant aujourd'hui on
essaye de rassembler si l'on peut dire
les chefs-d'oeuvre disparu garants de la
mémoire de la parfumerie l'osmothèque
possède 800 parfum disparu jean pierre
léaud en a lui même refusé deux sens à
partir de formules et de matières
premières un équilibre entre art et
science qui a permis de recréer à
l'identique des parfums mythiques du 20e
siècle
l'idée c'était de se concentrer sur une
thématique pour ses 25 ans et la
thématique et comment faire passer les
parfums à la postérité
dans cette optique là nous avons choisi
25 parfum qui n'existe plus dans les
circuits commerciaux mais dont nous
avons les formules et nous pouvons les
refaire ici à l'osmothèque un bon parfum
comment on peut appeler et quelques
jours de sensuel c'était quelque chose
et qui fait rêver comme la plupart des
parfums devrait toujours rêver ce
quelque chose - climatiques
particulièrement la parfumerie un témoin
du passé l'osmothèque et même
reconstitué l'eau de cologne portés par
napoléon en 1815
l'établissement organise régulièrement
des conférences olfactives et des
visites pour le public afin de
transmettre cet héritage évanescent la
prochaine a lieu le 6 juillet sur le
thème la grande histoire de la
parfumerie un mot de football à présent
le rose poursuit les quarts de finales
sont lancées le portugal vient de battre
la pologne le portugal qui compte une
forte communauté en ile de france et qui
a vibré
dans le stade bientz humain devant les
écrans également notamment dans les
yvelines les images sont signés patrick
jacques de dixmude
je pense que hahahaha et e et bah ça va
ça va jouer à la fin vers tirs au but je
pense avec je pense qu'ils vont pas
lâcher la sphère pronostics exacts pour
ce premier quart de finale entre la
pologne et le portugal
ce jeudi soir au bar girassol
d'elancourt les supporters de la seleçao
ont fait beaucoup de bruit dans ce
restaurant portugais pour encourager
leurs protégés
pourtant le match avait mal débuté pour
les coéquipiers de cristiano ronaldo
laisse t il encaisse un but dès la
deuxième minute de jeu puis vient la
délivrance renato sanchez égalise d'un
tir dévié à la 33e minute
les fans exulte le score n'évolue pas un
partout à la fin de la prolongation
direction les tirs au but le portugal
l'emportent 5 à 3 les portugais sont
qualifiés en demi finale on viendrait du
métier notre peuple c'est qu'on est unis
dans la douleur et dans la victoire
nous ce qui nous intéresse est d'aller
le plus loin possible ce qui compte ce
qu en demi-finale à l'eau si l'on
intègre ainsi plus la seleçao portugaise
affrontera mercredi prochain à lyon le
vainqueur de la rencontre pays de galles
belgique
le restaurant portugais girassol sortira
à nouveau les drapeaux lusitanien à
cette occasion
avant de passer à l'essentiel de la
semaine cette dernière information
valérie pécresse a annoncé ce vendredi
matin que le siège de la région allait
s'installer à saint-ouen en
seine-saint-denis dès 2017 le conseil
régional va donc quitter le 7e
arrondissement c'est l'une des mesures
les plus symboliques de ce début de
mandat
elle souhaite ainsi regroupés sur un
seul site des agents répartis aux quatre
coins de la capitale nous passons donc
maintenant à l'essentiel de la semaine
ce qu'il faut retenir de l'actualité
locale depuis lundi elle publie
tablissements public interdépartemental
des yvelines et des hauts-de-seine est
entré dans sa phase opérationnelle
ce matin donc nous avons pris des
décisions importantes autour de
l'aménagement du territoire
l'aménagement du territoire pour être
bref simple clair c'est la construction
de logements et d'équipements la
construction de logements pour loger les
yvelinois les alto séquanais et les
équipements qui vont avec ses
constructions de logements premièrement
on doit révolutionner la façon
d'apprendre la pédagogie ça passe par le
numérique est ici dans le campus
connectés dans le savoir-faire du campus
connectés de bruit il ya ces
technologies là qui sont domestiqués
deuxièmement nous avons en termes de
stratégie immobilière de faire des
locaux à la fois confortables
accueillant hospitalier nouvelle façon
d'apprendre et en même temps respectueux
de l'environnement aussi un autre défi
et je trouvais qu'il ya pas de mille
visites plus approprié que que celle ci
pour voir des expériences concrètes de
réussite de la transformation numérique
de la pédagogie et de la transformation
durable de l'immobilier je trouve que
c'est dommage parce que barman ils ont
bien baissé puisque effectivement ils
ont faim
instinct tout zone quoi tout dézoner et
puis bal à nouveau augmentation c'est
quand on les prend tout le temps savez
on est mécontent à folha
si c'est pour apporter des financements
supplémentaires sûr que c'est une bonne
chose
je compris honnêtement quand on compare
par rapport aux autres capitales dans le
monde en europe
je connais pas très cher finalement
depuis deux ans la mosquée invite
également différentes personnalités
politiques à venir échanger autour de
l'islam ne voulait pas pratiquer un
islam refermé sur lui-même
l'islam fait partie de la société
française est trop de mes connaissances
ou de clichés son véhicule et est avant
tout c'est un mois de générosité de
partage donc c'est pour ça qu'on invite
tout le temps d'autres personnes aussi
des personnes d'autres confessions qui
seront invités ce soir à venir partager
ce moment de générosité
aujourd'hui c'est le lancement de ces
api 2016 qui pour nous pour les maisons
des familles est un moment fort de
l'année puisque nous rencontrons
beaucoup de plaisir war et le but étant
aussi de que les gens se rencontrent et
forme du lien entre eux daisy c'est le
nom de cet appareil un outil adapté pour
répondre aux besoins des personnes
handicapées ou malvoyantes le lecteur
permet d'écouter un livre sonore ou un
cd à plaisir la bibliothèque du château
s'est équipé les touches à sont conçus
non vraiment pour le touché donc si la
personne veut arrêter l'éjecter il
suffit d'appuyer jeu l'équipe d'irlande
qui avait pour camp de base de
versailles est rentrée chez elle ce
lundi après sa défaite contre l'équipe
de france en 8e de finale après avoir
été mené 1 à 0 les bleus ont su rebondir
pour l'emporter 2 1 en deuxième période
grâce à un doublé d'antoine griezmann
match évidemment été très suivie dans
les yvelines dans le barreau paris à
versailles
une centaine de supporters maquiller ou
disait aux couleurs de la france
le chiffre d'affaires de ce bureau de
tabac a augmenté de 3% grâce à l'euro
deux constats beaucoup de vainqueurs
pour le match italie belgique
en revanche de nombreux perdants pour
les rencontres du portugal
ça dépend des matches je veux jouer à
200 euros
oh moi c'est 5 euros ou le match papus
j'suis pas flambeur dans ce lieu
prestigieux de l'orangerie un hôte de
marque à l'origine de ce bal kamel ouali
chorégraphe de la star academy ou de
comédies musicales comme les dicos
moment
l'idée c'est de faire revivre aux gens
de notre époque les grandes fêtes du
château de versailles
à l'époque de louis xiv alors avec une
musique actuelle avec avec le voilà avec
la nouvelle technologie avec tout ça
mais qui quand même cette émotion que
les gens à l'époque pouvaient pouvait
vivre la fin de ce journal dans un
instant volé l'essentiel des idées
sorties et loisirs avec le 7-8 week-end
présenté préparé par mélanie poké le
journal revient lundi aux horaires
habituels avec florane parfait